folks live in Michigan yes I live and
that's where you grew up for a lot of
your childhood hmm do they keep up with
your career through the internet because
I'm curious if they're sophisticated in
that way my parents don't know anything
about the internet and whenever there's
like a nice article or anything about me
on the Internet they asked me to send
them a clipping yeah like like they want
me to clip it out of the newspaper so
they don't know my parents are so bad at
the Internet and the computer that they
just tack on viruses and then wait for
me to visit the one time of year to like
rid them of all the viruses right so or
like my dad will like search my name on
Google and go to page 30 and when you go
to page 30 there's not good things on
page 30 of Google yeah the beginning is
always pretty good but if you keep going
it's mostly like you know just
photoshopped versions of people with
like penises everywhere but you're in
there yeah yeah I know that's a true
story let's just make it clear that so
your father goes looking up for
information about you on Google yeah and
then he sees you all these pictures of
you and there are penises involved yeah
just this and it's of coffee obviously
faked yeah yeah but and then what do you
do you just be upset he had to walk him
down the cliff that like I didn't take a
photo with all these dicks in it go he
must call you and be like yeah he was so
angry he was angry at that angry angry
okay well he was angry because he
thought I was selling myself to a life
of like just you know porn then I was
doing like sea-level porn not even like
he was just mad that it wasn't higher
quality boy yeah these penises these
aren't good-looking penises yeah he just
even I raised you better than this yeah
so it was just like you know he just
wanted like top-tier pornography
so glad my parents can't have the
Internet but he still like turns the
computer off by pulling the plug
yeah yeah we're in trouble but we'd
better unplug it it could catch fire in
the night I'm for certain that my
parents have gotten like all of their
personal identity stolen and these
daughters right right yeah they're like
there's a guy there's probably my dad
also lives in Texas and like Tallahassee
if he's the one posting the plague view
yeah he's a he's a Russian bot bot with
it it's just a fetish for a lot of
penises
you